As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal. And with seven rewards, I'm just $4.
作为7-Eleven的脆皮鸡肉三明治，大家总说我很大声。我想说，对啊，我知道。我很脆。你难道指望我低声细语吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反省一下吧。我的确很难搞。我很张扬，很多汁。给我加点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一整顿大餐。而且有了7 rewards积分，我只要4美元。
Quiet. No. Crispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 36-2326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. As a species, we humans have an extra long childhood. Our closest primate relatives are more or less self-sufficient by about age seven,
安静。不。又脆又多汁，只要4美元？没错。仅在711有售。区域代码36-2326，参与门店优惠，售完即止，完整条款请参见活动海报。作为一个物种，人类的童年期格外漫长。我们最近的灵长类亲戚在大约七岁时就基本能自给自足了，
nearly a decade before human kids are ready to face the world on their own. And as any parent or caregiver knows, children are costly. They take an extraordinary amount of time, energy, and resources to raise. Children are not simply messier and less sophisticated versions of adults either. A baby's brain has unusual capabilities. It's optimized to explore the world and seek new knowledge and experiences. Knowing this has implications for how we think about the purpose of childhood and how we raise and educate our children, even how we might develop artificial intelligence inspired
这比人类儿童准备好独自面对世界的时间早了将近十年。正如任何父母或看护者所知，养育孩子代价高昂。抚养他们需要耗费惊人的时间、精力和资源。孩子们也不仅仅是成年人更邋遢、更不成熟的版本。婴儿的大脑拥有不寻常的能力。它经过优化，能够探索世界、寻求新的知识和体验。了解这一点对我们思考童年的目的、我们如何抚养和教育孩子，甚至我们如何开发受
by children's remarkable learning abilities. So why do we humans have such a long childhood? What's in it for us as a species? What can we learn about our adult cells by looking at kids' brains? And is there anything we adults can do to become more open, curious, and childlike in our thinking. How might that be beneficial? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Allison
儿童卓越学习能力启发的})-(\n)-人工智能，都有着重要的意义。那么，为什么人类会有这么漫长的童年？这对我们作为一个物种有什么意义？通过观察孩子的大脑，我们能对自己成年后有什么样的了解？我们成年人有没有什么办法能让自己的思维变得更加开放、好奇和像孩子一样？这又会有什么好处呢？欢迎收看《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是艾莉森·格普尼克（Allison）博士。
Gopnik, a professor of psychology and an affiliate professor of philosophy at the University of California, Berkeley. She studies how children learn and come to understand the world around them. Over her four-decade career, she's published more than 100 journal articles and many books, including her most recent The Gardener and the Carpenter, what the new science of child development tells us about the relationship between parents and children. She's also written widely about topics including play, schooling, the relationship between grandparents and grandchildren, artificial intelligence, and much more that we'll try to touch on today if we can.
戈普尼克，加州大学伯克利分校心理学教授、哲学兼任教授。她研究儿童如何学习和理解周围的世界。在其四十年的职业生涯中，她发表了100多篇学术期刊文章和许多书籍，包括她最近出版的《园丁与木匠：儿童发展的新科学告诉我们父母与孩子之间的关系是什么》（The Gardener and the Carpenter, what the new science of child development tells us about the relationship between parents and children）。她还就游戏、学校教育、祖孙关系、人工智能等许多主题广泛撰文，如果时间允许，我们今天将尽量触及这些话题。
Thank you for joining us, Dr. Gopnik. Happy to be here. You have written that kids are the R&D, the research and development division of humanity. That's a really great image. Can you tell us what you mean by that? Well, one of the interesting puzzles, as you mentioned, is why is it that we have such a long period of childhood? Why is it that, you know, not to put too fine a point on it, our babies are useless. In fact, you could argue they're sort of worse than useless because we have to put so much time and energy into taking care of them.
非常感谢您能做客我们的节目，戈普尼克博士。很高兴来到这里。您曾写道，孩子们是人类的R&D（研发部门）。这是一个非常棒的比喻。您能跟我们谈谈这是什么意思吗？嗯，正如您所提到的，其中一个有趣的谜题是，为什么我们的童年期会这么长？为什么，呃，直白点说，我们的婴儿是“无用”的。事实上，你甚至可以说他们某种程度上比无用还要糟糕，因为我们需要投入大量的时间和精力去照顾他们。
And that's a kind of evolutionary puzzle. And it turns out that if you look across many different species, you see this relationship between how long a period of childhood an animal has and essentially how smart, how good they are at learning as adults. So you see this not just for humans, but you see it among primates. You even see it among birds. So that, for instance, ravens and crows are very, very smart birds. And they have a much longer period, fledgling periods than other. less intelligent birds. So that raises the question,
这是一个进化上的谜题。事实证明，如果你观察许多不同的物种，你会发现动物童年期的长短与它们成年后的聪明程度、学习能力之间存在着这种联系。不仅人类如此，你在灵长类动物中也能看到这一点。甚至在鸟类中也能看到。比如，渡鸦和乌鸦是非常非常聪明的鸟类。与其它不太聪明的鸟类相比，它们的雏鸟期要长得多。这就引发了一个问题，
what is it that that period is doing? Was there some function it's serving that makes it worth the cost of taking care of those helpless babies? And the best explanation we have is that there's a kind of trade-off between different kinds of things that a brain or a mind can do. In artificial intelligence,
那段时期究竟在做什么？它是否在发挥某种功能，使得照顾那些无助的婴儿所付出的代价变得值得？我们所拥有的最佳解释是，大脑或思维所能做的事的不同方面之间存在着某种权衡。在人工智能领域，
they talk about this is the explore-exploit trade-off. And the idea is that you can't really have a system that's both really, really, really, at doing things and really, really good at learning things. Because the things that you need to be effective at acting, having very narrow focus, acting very swiftly, only considering a couple of options at a time, those are all the things you need to,
他们将此称为“探索与利用的权衡”（explore-exploit trade-off）。其核心思想是，你不可能真正拥有一个既擅长做事、又非常擅长学习的系统。因为要想在行动上高效、具备极窄的专注力、行动极其迅速、每次只考虑一两个选项，你需要具备所有这些条件，
you know, sort of be an executive, go out and make things happen. And they're very different from the kinds of things that you need to be able to take in as much information as you can from the world, consider as many different possibilities as you can, go out and explore and take risks just for the things, sake of getting information. Those two things are really genuinely in tension with one another. And what I've argued is that childhood is evolution's way of resolving that tension. So childhood gives us this period where we can we can just explore. And the reason why we can do it is
你知道的，这有点像成为一个高管，走出去把事情办成。这与你需要从世界中尽可能多地吸收信息、尽可能多地考虑各种可能性、为了获取信息而出去探索和冒险的能力，是截然不同的。这两者之间确实存在着真正的紧张关系。而我的观点是，童年是进化解决这种紧张关系的方式。童年给了我们这样一个时期，我们可以尽情地去探索。我们之所以能够做到这一点，是因为
because the one thing that babies are really good at is being as cute as they could possibly be and that that makes everybody else around them want to put in the time and work and investment of taking care of them. And then that period let's let, let, let, let, an animal explorer learn in a kind of free-ranging way. And then, of course, as an adult, you can take the things that you learned in that childhood period and actually put them to use to be able to do all the kind of planning and action and executive function that we do as adults. What do you think it feels like to be a kid and have your mind in this exploratory state
婴儿真正擅长的一件事就是尽可能地可爱，这会让周围的每个人都愿意投入时间、精力和心血去照顾他们。然后，这段时期让动物能够以一种自由发散的方式去探索和学习。当然，到了成年之后，你就可以把在童年时期学到的东西付诸实践，去完成我们成年人所做的所有规划、行动和执行功能。你觉得作为一个孩子、让自己的思维一直处于这种探索状态是一种什么样的体验？
all the time? Is there anything that we experience in adulthood that might come close? Yeah. So it's a really good question about, you know, what is it like to be a base? There's the famous paper by the philosopher Thomas Nagel about what is it like to be a bat and what is it like to be a baby. And again, I think part of the big picture of the point of the work that I've done is it's very easy for people to think about babies as if they're sort of defective grownups. The way to think about development is, okay, there's this absolute marvelous peak of human development, which is, you know, being, I don't know, the 30-year-old philosopher who's writing the article. And then everything else is just sort of building up to that or else falling off from that later on when you say become an old lady the way I am now.
成年后的我们所经历的事情中，有没有哪件能与之接近？是的。所以这是一个非常好的问题，关于“作为一个婴儿是什么感觉”。哲学家托马斯·内格尔（Thomas Nagel）有一篇著名的论文，探讨了“成为一只蝙蝠是什么感觉”，而这就像是“成为一个婴儿是什么感觉”。同样，我认为我所做的工作的核心观点之一，是人们很容易把婴儿看作是有缺陷的成年人。看待发展的正确方式应该是：好吧，人类发展有一个绝对奇妙的巅峰，那就是，比如说，30岁正在写文章的哲学家。然后其他的一切要么是在为这个巅峰做准备，要么就是在走下坡路——比如像我现在的年纪，变成老太太之后。
But of course, from an evolutionary perspective, that doesn't make very much sense, right? And you can see that in discussions about consciousness too. So there's been this sort of idea that, you know, the 35-year-old philosopher in his armchair is the peak of consciousness. And when he's sitting there thinking about consciousness, that's the greatest kind of consciousness you could have. So that means that babies who are obviously not doing that sort of thing must be less conscious than adults. But I think there's a good argument we made that babies are actually more conscious than adults. And the reason is if you think about what the function of their, the functional characteristics of their experience, the fact that they're learning a lot, the fact that everything around them is new,
但当然，从进化的角度来看，这并没有什么太大意义，对吧？你在关于意识的讨论中也能看到这一点。因此有一种观点认为，坐在扶手椅上的35岁哲学家代表了意识的巅峰。当他坐在那里思考意识时，那就是你所能拥有的最伟大的意识。这意味着那些明显没有在做这种事的婴儿，其意识必定不如成年人。但我认为有充分的理由证明，婴儿实际上比成年人拥有更丰富的意识。原因在于，如果你考虑他们的经验的功能特征——他们正在学习大量的新事物，他们周围的一切都是崭新的，
even the fact that when you look at their brains, there's a tremendous amount of plasticity, as neuroscientists say, a lot of change going on. All that fits with a picture that they're actually more open to more of what's going on in the world around them than we typically are when we're adults sort of stuck in our little narrow internal paths. And I think they're, you know, for instance, the kind of classic Buddhist psychology
甚至正如神经科学家所说，当你观察他们的大脑时，会发现存在着极高的可塑性，有大量的变化正在发生。所有这些都符合这样一幅图景：与我们作为成年人陷入自己狭隘的内在路径时相比，他们实际上对周围世界中正在发生的事情更加开放。我认为他们，举个例子，比如经典的佛教心理学
has pointed out this contrast between the way we think when we're just into our own heads and focused on one specific thing, and the way that in some kinds of meditative states, like open awareness states, for example, we're suddenly open to everything that's going on around us. We're aware of everything around us. I think another example is travel for adults. So when you go to a new place, you are not very functional.
就指出了这种对比：一种是我们只局限于自己的思维、专注于某一件具体事情时的思考方式；另一种是在某些冥想状态下，比如开放觉知状态（open awareness states），我们突然对周围发生的一切都敞开心扉，意识到周围的一切。我认为另一个例子是成年人的旅行。当你去到一个新的地方时，你的功能往往会失常。
You don't, you often, you know, at least like me, you leave your, you know, you leave your, your charger in five different places. and you're not very stressful to even get from, you know, your hotels at the conference center. But on the other hand, you're you're much more aware of everything that's going on around you. And, you know, there's a couple of days in the new place in Beijing or Paris feel as if they're full of consciousness in a really deep, important way that it's not like your everyday experience. And then the most recent thing that I think might be revealing about this is that there's some recent work that suggests, that people under the effects of certain kinds of psychedelic substances, that there's been a great deal of work recently about kind of renaissance of work
你经常，你知道的，至少像我一样，会把充电器忘在五个不同的地方。甚至从酒店去会议中心的路上，你都会觉得压力重重。但另一方面，你对周围发生的一切却有更敏锐的感知。在一个新地方（比如北京或巴黎）待上几天，会让你觉得充满了意识，那种感觉是如此深刻而重要，完全不同于你的日常经验。接下来，我认为最新能揭示这一点的现象是，最近的一些研究表明，在某些迷幻物质的作用下——最近关于迷幻药物及其潜在效果的“复兴”式研究有很多——
on psychedelics and their potential effects. And the brain effects of those looks like from the new studies that the brain effects of those substances are a lot like putting the brain back into its childhood state, the state of a great deal of plasticity and not very much control, not very much frontal control. And again, that sort of, you know, if you sort of think about, I think everybody who's seen a baby has had that experience of thinking, gee, that baby is just really out there, right? You watch the baby looking at their hands or looking at their mobile and thinking this is the most amazing thing in the world.
从最新研究来看，这些物质对大脑的影响，很像是将大脑重新置于其童年状态：一个具有高度可塑性、控制力不强、前额叶控制不多的状态。同样，如果你去想一想，我想每个见过婴儿的人都有过这种感觉：天哪，那个婴儿真的太放飞自我了，对吧？你看着婴儿端详自己的双手，或是看着他们的婴儿床挂饰，觉得这是世界上最了不起的事情。
Everything's a discovery. Sort of fit. That's right. So that the babies seem to be more tuned into even. little details of the world around them, even though they don't have the kind of focused internal, all right, here's what I'm going to do tomorrow, here's what I'm going to do the day after that, that we do as adults. You've talked about how children's brains are lanterns of consciousness, while adult brains are like spotlights of consciousness. That's what you're talking about here,
万物皆是发现。这种状态很契合。没错，婴儿似乎更能调动自己去关注周围世界的微小细节，尽管他们不像我们成年人那样拥有那种专注的内在规划——“好吧，明天我要做什么，后天我要做什么”。你曾谈到过，孩子的大脑是意识的灯笼，而成年人的大脑则像意识的聚光灯。这就是你在这里谈论的，
right? And what do you mean by that? Exactly. So the metaphor about attention, for example, being a spotlight, that's a very old metaphor in cognitive psychology. And there's lots and lots of evidence to suggest that that's true. So for adults, so there's even, your listeners probably know about the famous guerrilla experiment where there's a phenomenon called inattentional blindness, which means that we as adults literally don't see things
对吧？你这话是什么意思？完全正确。例如，关于注意力是一盏聚光灯的比喻，这在认知心理学中是一个非常古老比喻。有大量证据表明事实确实如此。对于成年人来说，甚至——你的听众可能知道著名的“大猩猩实验”，其中存在一种被称为“无意盲视”（inattentional blindness）的现象，这意味着我们作为成年人，对于那些
that we're not paying attention to. So if someone says, okay, here's, you know, two people and they're throwing balls back and forth, and I want you to concentrate on how many times did the ball move, and then a gorilla walks right through the middle of the screen, people literally don't see the gorilla, which is sort of amazing. But it gives you a sense of how narrow and bright that spotlight is. And I think if you look at babies and young children, you're not seeing that kind of inattentional blindness. The focus of what the babies are doing is much
我们没有注意到的东西，可以说是视而不见。所以如果有人说，好吧，这里有两个人正在传球，我希望你集中精力数一数球移动了多少次，接着一只大猩猩径直穿过屏幕中央，人们居然真的看不到那只大猩猩，这简直太神奇了。但这让你体会到那束聚光灯有多么狭窄和明亮。我想如果你观察婴儿和幼儿，你不会看到这种无意盲视。婴儿注意力的聚焦点要宽得多。
wider. And of course, that has some disadvantages, like it's hard for babies to pay attention or to concentrate. But, you know, one of the things I say is when we say that children are bad at paying attention. What we really mean is they're bad at not paying attention. So what they're bad at is filtering out all the other kinds of things that are going on around them, that fascinating little piece of dust on the floor or the sound of that airplane high up in the sky that we grownups don't even notice. They're bad at not paying attention to those things and just paying attention to the thing they're supposed to be paying attention to, like putting on their jacket to get to school. In recent years, you've become interested in the other end of the
当然，这也有一些缺点，比如婴儿很难集中注意力。但你知道，我常说的一句话是，当我们说孩子们不擅长集中注意力时，我们真正想表达的意思是，他们不擅长“不”集中注意力。他们不擅长的是过滤掉周围发生的其他所有事情——地板上那个迷人的小灰尘颗粒，或者高空中那架飞机传来的声音，这些都是我们成年人甚至都不会注意到的。他们不擅长忽略这些事情，只去关注他们理应关注的事情，比如为了去学校而穿上夹克。近年来，你对
the lifespan as well. I know you've written about in addition to our having long childhoods, that humans also have unusually long old age. And you believe that both of these factors are critical to human intelligence and adaptability. Why is that? So there's two things that are that are really interesting about this. One is, as we know, humans have this long, essentially grandmotherhood, this post-manipausal period of about 20 years, which, really makes us different from our closest primate relatives and makes us different from for most other animals. And that's always been true. That was true even when we were foragers that women live for 20 years after menopause. And of course, that's also true for men. So men live for that extra 20 years as well.
生命周期的另一端也产生了兴趣。我知道你写过文章指出，除了拥有漫长的童年，人类还拥有异常漫长的老年。你认为这两个因素对于人类的智能和适应能力都至关重要。为什么会这样？关于这一点，有两个非常有趣的地方。第一，如我们所知，人类拥有这种漫长的、本质上属于“祖母期”的绝经后时期，大约持续20年。这确实使我们区别于我们最近的灵长类亲戚，也使我们区别于大多数其他动物。而且情况一直如此。即使在我们还是采集者的时候，女性在绝经后也能活20年。当然，男性也是如此。所以男性也能多活这20年。
It's not quite as vivid an evolutionary paradox with men, but it's true in both cases. And that happened pretty quickly. So then there's this puzzle about why do we have that extra 20 years there? And one piece is that, and you know, that 20 years comes with decreased strength and speed and all the things that we know about as we as we get older. And one piece clearly is that those immature, intelligent children need a lot more parental investment. They need a lot more taking care of than, say, primate babies do. And there's some very nice evidence in anthropology that it's those older people who are actually putting in the time and energy and investment to just help keep those children alive.
对于男性来说，这并不是一个那么鲜明的进化悖论，但这在两种情况下都是事实。而且这一现象出现得相当快。这就带来了一个谜题：为什么我们会有这额外的20年？其中一个原因是——你知道，这20年伴随着力量和速度的下降，以及我们随着年龄增长而经历的所有这些众所周知的事情。另一个显而易见的原因是，那些尚未成熟、聪明的孩子需要更多的父母投入。与灵长类婴儿相比，他们需要更多的照顾。人类学中有一些非常精彩的证据表明，正是这些老年人付出了时间和精力与投资，来帮助维持这些孩子的生命。
But there's an even more interesting story. The one creature that we know of that also has post-metapausal grandmothers, aside from humans, are orcas. Killer whale. It might seem a bit surprising. Why orchids? Well, it turns out orcas are among the few other species that also has cultural traditions where a particular pod of orcas will choose a particular kind of food, you know, krill or or shrimp or other fish.
但还有一个更有趣的故事。除了人类之外，我们所知的唯一拥有绝经后祖母的生物是虎鲸（killer whale）。杀人鲸。这或许会让人觉得有点惊讶。为什么是虎鲸？事实证明，虎鲸是少数几种拥有文化传统的物种之一，特定的虎鲸种群会选择特定种类的食物（比如磷虾、虾或其他鱼类）。
And it turns out that it's actually the grandmothers who are leading the pod who are pointing to the sources of the food and and seem to be responsible for some of this cultural transmission. Now, one of the things that I think has become increasingly clear about, human is that we depend on these cultural traditions again much more than any other species other species have these traditions but it's you know it's sort of the secret of our success it's one of the things that's most distinctive about us if you think about all the differences between what we're doing now as we sit here on our our Zoom computers and what we were doing not so long ago in the
事实证明，实际上是带领种群的祖母们在指引食物的来源，并似乎对这种文化的传承负有责任。现在，关于人类，越来越清晰的一点是，我们对这些文化传统的依赖比任何其他物种都要多得多。其他物种也有这些传统，但这（文化积累）可以说是我们成功的秘密，也是最让我们与众不同的特征之一。如果你想想我们现在坐在这里用Zoom电脑所做的事情，与不久前我们在
Pleistocene all of that's due to cumulative culture and if you think about elders like grandmothers one of the things that they can do is pass on information about what people have discovered in the past. So before writing the 150 years between my grandchildren and my grandparents, I can tell them stories about my own grandparents, that's about as far back as you could go. And there's some fascinating anthropological evidence that that's one of the main things that elders are doing. So a lot of this work is in a special issue of the philosophical transactions of the Royal
更新世（Pleistocene）所做的事情之间的所有区别，所有这一切都归功于累积文化（cumulative culture）。如果你想到像祖母这样的长辈，他们能做的事情之一就是传递关于人们过去发现的信息。在有文字记载之前，从我的孙辈到我的祖父母之间有150年的跨度，我可以给他们讲我自己的祖父母的故事，这差不多就是你能追溯到的极限了。有一些迷人的人类学证据表明，这是长辈们在做的事情的主要内容之一。因此，很多这方面的工作都发表在皇家学会哲学汇刊（Philosophical Transactions of the Royal Society）的一个特刊上，
Society that I edited recently and there's a marvelous piece by Michael Gervyn who was looking at hunting. And what he points out, this will be familiar to everybody in COVID time, is that it's quite hard to actually do something well and teach someone else how to do it well. So when we make pancakes in my house in the wonderful pre-COVID days with my grandchildren, one of the discoveries that I made is when the grandchildren weren't there, it's so much faster to make the pancakes. It's like four times. four times as fast. On Sunday mornings I keep saying to my husband, how come this is going so quickly?
这是我最近编辑的，其中有一篇迈克尔·格尔文（Michael Gervyn）写的精彩文章，他研究了狩猎活动。他指出的一点——这在新冠疫情期间对每个人来说都会很熟悉——要把一件事做好，同时还要把如何做好这件事教给别人，其实是相当困难的。所以，在美好的疫情前岁月里，当我和孙辈们在我家里做煎饼时，我发现的一个事实是，当孙辈们不在的时候，做煎饼的速度要快得多。简直快了四倍。
And I think everyone who has children at home is aware of that. And what Gervin found was that the hunters, sort of the prime of life, 35-year-old hunters, were the ones who were most effective. But they weren't teaching as much as the elders were. So the elders weren't as good at actually doing the hunting anymore. They weren't as strong, but they were skilled.
快了四倍。周日早上我一直对丈夫说，为什么这次进展这么快？我想家里有孩子的每个人都对此深有体会。格尔文发现，正值壮年、35岁的猎人是最有效率的。但他们不像长辈那样擅长教导。所以长辈们在实际狩猎方面已经不如以前那么厉害了。他们不再那么强壮，但他们经验丰富。
They were the ones who had. have the knowledge. So what happened was that those older hunters were going out with the kids and actually teaching them, showing them what was going on, helping them to figure out what was going on in the world. Now, my own personal, this is just a just a so story, but I think a kind of slightly comforting just so story for us oldsters is you think about that function. Another thing that Gervin found was that the elders were the ones who were passing on the stories and the songs and the big structure of how the world worked. And again, if you think about what you do as a grandmother, that's exactly what you do, right?
他们是掌握知识的人。因此，发生的情况是，那些年长的猎人会和孩子们一起出去，实际教导他们，向他们展示发生了什么，帮助他们弄清楚世界上正在发生的事情。现在，我个人的——这只是一个“吉卜林童话式的叙事”（just-so story），但我认为这对于我们这些老年人来说是一个稍微有点安慰的叙事——如果你想想那个功能。格尔文发现的另一件事是，长辈们是传递故事、歌曲以及世界如何运作宏大结构的人。再次，如果你想想作为一个祖母你会做的事情，那正是你所做的，对吧？
Tell stories about when you were a kid and sing songs. And if you think about it from a cognitive perspective, again, I think something that's really important that we haven't emphasized enough in psychology is this idea of tradeoffs, that we can't have a system that does everything perfectly, or even does everything well. There's always tradeoffs between some things and others. So I think there might be a trade-off between being able to remember what happened yesterday, right, which is not all that helpful if you're trying to teach a new generation. They know what happened yesterday. But remembering what happened, you know, 50 years ago, that might actually really be helpful.
讲讲你小时候的故事，唱唱歌。如果你从认知的角度来思考，同样，我认为心理学中有一个非常重要、但我们尚未给予足够强调的概念，那就是“权衡”的概念：我们不可能拥有一个能把所有事情都做到完美的系统，甚至无法把所有事情都做好。某些事物与另一些事物之间总是存在权衡。所以我认为，能够记住昨天发生了什么之间可能存在一种权衡——如果你正试图教导新一代人，记住昨天发生的事其实并没有太大帮助。他们自己就知道昨天发生了什么。但记住50年前发生了什么，那可能真的会对他们有所帮助。
So that's slightly comforting when for us, people who can't remember where we put our glasses yesterday, but are really, really good about telling stories about what happened when we were a little girl. Yeah, back in the day. So we humans also have a long adolescence. And research shows that when you look at things like risk-taking behaviors, that our brains don't fully mature until our mid-20s. I'm just wondering, are teen brains more like children's brains or adults' brains? Yeah, this is a really fascinating piece. And in a piece that I did in Piano Acid in 2017, really for the first time in my career, I started looking at adolescents and thinking about adolescents. And what happened was one of those nice empirical things where I wanted to, you know, this argument about the kids being more exploratory isn't just sort of made up out of whole cloth. We've done a whole bunch of studies that show that children are actually better at learning than adults in cases where the hypothesis is sort of unusual or in cases where you have to sort of take a risk to be able to get the information that you need. And so we wanted to see how that unfolded over the lifespan. So we tested kids from people from five until up through adulthood. And what we discovered somewhat surprisingly was especially if it was a social task,
所以这对于我们这些记不清昨天把眼镜放在哪里、却非常擅长讲自己小时候故事的人来说，稍微有一点安慰。是的，回到过去。所以我们人类也有一个漫长的青春期。研究表明，当你观察诸如冒险行为之类的事情时，我们的大脑直到20代中期才完全成熟。我只是在想，青少年的大脑更像儿童的大脑还是成年人的大脑？是的，这是一个非常迷人的部分。在2017年我为《PNAS》撰写的一篇文章中，我职业生涯中第一次开始审视青少年并思考青春期。发生的事情是一个很好的实证案例：我想让——关于孩子更具探索性的这种论据并非凭空捏造。我们做过一整串研究，表明在假设有点不寻常、或者你必须冒一定风险才能获得所需信息的情况下，儿童实际上比成年人更擅长学习。因此，我们想看看这种能力在整个人生周期中是如何展开的。所以我们测试了从五岁到成年期不同年龄段的人。我们有点惊讶地发现，特别是如果是社交任务，
a task about how you understand other people. The adolescents, what you saw is this really interesting curve where the preschoolers were very flexible. And then they became less flexible as they got to school age. And adults were not flexible at all. But the adolescents actually had this new peak of flexibility. And that fits with a lot of the neuroscience that suggests that especially in domains that have to do with the social world, you see this kind of reintroduction of plasticity and risk taking in adolescence. And, you know, if you think about it just even intuitively, any of you who've raised a child, right? You know, they're these crazy, difficult, imaginative preschoolers.
一个关于你如何理解他人的任务。对于青少年，你看到了一个非常有趣的曲线：学龄前儿童非常灵活。然后当他们到了学龄期，灵活性变低了。而成年人则完全不灵活。但青少年实际上展现出了一个新的灵活性巅峰。这与许多神经科学的研究结果非常吻合，这些研究表明，特别是在与社交世界相关的领域，你在青春期会看到这种可塑性和冒险精神的“重新引入”。而且，如果你凭直觉去想，任何抚养过孩子的人，对吧？你知道，他们是那些疯狂、难缠、富有想象力的学龄前儿童。
And then they turn into, like, I am convinced that a nine-year-old is like the sanest person on the face. of the universe, right? Like nine-year-old, my, my oldest grandson is nine now. And it's just, you know, he's calm, he's sane, he's rational, he's thoughtful. And then they hit adolescents and suddenly, wait a minute, it's like there's three again. They're doing all these things because you told them not to and they're crazy and they're taking risks. And I think there's actually some evidence to suggest that adolescence is like this secondary period of exploration, especially about things like how the social world works, how the social world should be organized. And a lot of the risk taking that we see both in preschoolers and in adolescence
然后他们变成了——我坚信九岁的孩子就像世界上最理智的人，对吧？比如九岁的孩子，我的大孙子现在九岁了。这就是，你知道的，他很冷静、很理智、很理性、很体贴。然后他们迎来了青春期，突然之间，等一下，感觉就像回到了三岁。他们做所有这些事情都是因为你告诉他们不要做，他们变得疯狂并且开始冒险。我认为实际上有一些证据表明，青春期就像是探索的第二个时期，尤其是关于社交世界如何运作、社交世界应该如何组织的事情。我们在学龄前儿童和青少年身上看到的许多冒险行为，
is connected to this explore, exploit, tradeoff about trying to get more information versus taking risks than having costs. You've talked about how your experiences as a sister and as a mother influenced your research and your career path. Can you just tell our listeners a little bit about your own history and how you became interested in studying children?
都与这种关于“尝试获取更多信息与承担成本风险”的“探索-利用”权衡有关。你曾谈到，作为姐姐和母亲的经历是如何影响你的研究和职业生涯的。你能给我们的听众简单讲讲你自己的历史，以及你是如何对研究儿童产生兴趣的吗？
Because that wasn't considered a serious field of study at the time when you began, right? Well, you know, it's interesting because I actually began my career as a philosopher, and I'm still an affiliate in philosophy, and I still think that's kind of what my real vocation is.
因为在你刚开始的时候，这并不被认为是一个严肃的研究领域，对吧？嗯，你知道，这很有趣，因为我其实是以哲学家身份开始我的职业生涯的，而且我依然是哲学的附属研究员，我仍然认为那才是我真正的天职。
That's the thing that I'm best at. And I was interested as a philosopher, in some of these big questions about how the world works. And the deepest question, the one that I was and continue to be really the most interested, the one that's really really propelled my entire career. Part of the reason why I'm interested in AI now, for example, is how is it that we could ever know about the world around us? So all that gets to us from the world are a bunch of photons hitting the back of our
那是我最擅长的事情。作为一个哲学家，我对关于世界如何运作的一些宏大问题很感兴趣。最深奥的问题，也是我过去和现在都最感兴趣、真正推动了我整个职业生涯的问题。比如我现在对人工智能感兴趣的部分原因，就在于我们怎么可能了解我们周围的世界？因为所有从世界传达到我们这里的信息，只是一束撞击我们眼后方的光子以及耳部空气的扰动。然而，我们却了解一个充满了物体、人、思想，以及最终的（你知道的）夸克和遥远行星的世界。这在我看来总是相当了不起的。这是一个深刻的哲学问题，可以一直追溯到柏拉图和亚里士多德。这是如何运作的？这怎么可能？
eyes and disturbances of air at our ears. And yet we know about a world that's full of objects and people and thoughts and eventually, you know, quarks and distant planets. And it always seemed kind of remarkable to me. That's a deep philosophical question going all the way back to Plato and Aristotle. How does that work? How is that possible? But I was also the oldest of six children, which means that I was sort of a caregiver. And I had my first child when I was 23.
但同时我也是六个孩子中的老大，这意味着我某种程度上是一个照顾者。我在23岁时有了第一个孩子。
So really, my whole life is very few exceptions. I've been, I've been, and thank God for grandchildren. I've been engaged and involved with children. And it always seemed to me that children were the sensible people to look at if you wanted to ask that big question. Because they're the ones who are actually doing all of that learning. They're the ones who are figuring out how the world works. And that, you know, wasn't unique. Pige, the great founder of Covenous Development thought that.
所以实际上，除了极少数例外，我的整个人生——感谢上帝赐予孙辈——我一直都与儿童紧密相连、深度参与其中。在我看来，如果你想探究那个宏大的问题，儿童一直都是最明智的研究对象。因为他们才是真正进行所有这些学习的人。他们才是弄清楚世界如何运作的人。这并不是独一无二的。皮亚杰（Piaget），认知发展的伟大奠基人，就是这么认为的。
In fact, Socrates thought that looking at children was a way that you could answer those questions. But it was still, you know, for obvious reasons, children are, were and are, you know, stuff that kids, moms take care of. It's women's work. It's domestic. It doesn't quite have the kind of status and seriousness often that other, that other, other kinds of research have. So my sort of, I mean, literally from the time I was just starting out my career very intentionally, I set out. had a sort of choice point of should I just go and become a philosopher and be a woman who's doing the kinds of things that analytic philosophers talk about or should I embrace this very female enterprise of looking at children and just make people realize that looking at children was just as deep, just as interesting, just as significant as looking at brains or looking at computers or or doing reaction. or any other kinds of things that adults do.
事实上，苏格拉底也认为观察儿童是回答这些问题的一种途径。但出于显而易见的原因，儿童过去是、现在也依然是——那是妈妈们照顾的对象。这是女性的工作。它是家庭式的。它往往不具备其他类型的研究所拥有的那种地位和严肃性。所以我的某种程度上——我是说，从我职业生涯刚开始时起，我就非常刻意地面临一个抉择点：我是应该去当一个哲学家，做一个从事分析哲学家们谈论的事情的女性；还是应该拥抱这个非常女性化的、观察儿童的事业，并让人们意识到，观察儿童和观察大脑、观察计算机或做反应时研究，或者成年人所做的任何其他类型的事情一样深刻、有趣、意义重大。
I'm not sure I've completely succeeded at that, but that's sort of the mission. And I hope that my students are carrying on that mission. Has the fact that more women are entering research psychology contributed to the changes that you've seen in your field? Yeah, I think there's no doubt about that. So both the fact that more women are involved and the fact that more men are,
我不确定我在这方面是否取得了完全的成功，但这可以说是我的使命。我希望我的学生们能够将这个使命传承下去。越来越多的女性进入研究心理学领域，这一事实是否促成了你所看到的你所在领域的变革？是的，毫无疑问。既有更多女性参与这一事实，也有更多男性——
the fact that more men are involved with children, right? So one of the puzzles, for instance, you know, the really big revolution has been our understanding of babies and young children. So even when I started out, which is a while ago, but not that long ago, I remember people telling me when I was at Oxford that babies were decorticate, that they were like, you know, kind of like vegetables, that they didn't have a cortex. They couldn't really think. And even Pige, you know, the great founder of cognitive development thought that babies were, babies and young children up till about five were irrational and egocentric and solipsistic. And we've just totally turned that on its head. That views just 180 degrees different. So now we think that even the youngest babies both know more and learn more than we ever would have
更多男性参与到照顾儿童中来的事实，对吧？所以其中的一个谜题是，你知道的，真正巨大的革命是我们对婴儿和幼儿的理解。因此，甚至在我刚开始的时候——那是有一段时间了，但也没有那么久——我记得在牛津时有人告诉我，婴儿是没有皮层的（decorticate），他们就像是某种植物，没有大脑皮层。他们无法真正思考。甚至皮亚杰，认知发展的伟大奠基人，也认为婴儿——婴儿和直到五岁左右的幼儿——是无理取闹、以自我为中心且唯我论的。而我们已经彻底颠覆了这种看法。这种观点发生了180度的翻转。所以现在我们认为，即使是最小的婴儿，其所知和所学也远超我们以往的想象。
thought. But an interesting kind of puzzle is like, why were they so wrong for so long, right? I mean, what was it? How could how could all of these people, the smartest people, the philosophers, the psychologists, like psychiatrists, how could they've gotten it so wrong? Well, if they weren't the caregivers, they weren't having the same interaction every day with babies, right? I mean, would that be part of it? Exactly. And I think part of the reason was that the people who were actually spending time with babies did think, wait a minute, I think he recognized me. I think he understands this.
但一个有趣的问题是：为什么他们能错得那么离谱、持续那么久呢？我的意思是，那是什么原因？所有这些最聪明的人——哲学家、心理学家、精神病学家——怎么会错得这么彻底？嗯，如果他们不是照顾者，他们每天就不会和婴儿有相同的互动，对吧？我的意思是，这也是原因之一吗？完全正确。我认为原因之一在于，那些真正花时间陪伴婴儿的人确实会想：等等，我想他认出我了。我想他理解这个。
They had a rich sense of it. But of course, they weren't the people who were writing the books. And it's really striking to me now. I have this wonderful new four-month-old grandson who very sadly is often. in Montreal, but my granddaughter and grandson literally every morning send me a video of what the baby's doing. And I've realized, of course, that technology means that I get to see how he's imitating or he's looking or he's engaged. But of course, those are just a few moments during the day. A lot of the time during the day, a baby will be asleep or a baby will be fussy or a baby won't be doing
他们对此有着丰富的感知。但当然，他们并不是写书的人。现在这对我来说真的很触动。我有一个非常可爱的新四个月大的孙子，非常遗憾他经常在蒙特利尔，但我的孙女和孙子几乎每天早上都会给我发一段婴儿在做什么的视频。我意识到，当然，科技意味着我能看到他是如何模仿、如何注视或如何投入的。但当然，这些只是白天里的短短几个时刻。白天的大多数时间里，婴儿要么在睡觉，要么在哭闹，或者不会做那些真正展示他们有多聪明的行为。
those things that really demonstrate how smart they are. And it's kind of, if you didn't actually, you know, have the video phone sitting right there so that you could pick it up and do a video at the very moment when the baby's doing it, it would just seem like it was lost. And in fact, you know, again, if I think about it when we were starting out, you know, you wanted to record a baby. You had to take a big, heavy, you know, big heavy reel-to-reel recorder and a box full of equipment and hope that you could get something. And I'm wondering if, you know, the new technology means that we'll start getting more data and appreciating more just exactly what babies can do. Let's talk for a minute about your book, The Gardener and the Carpenter. You talk about
这就有点像，如果你没有把视频电话就放在那里，以便你能在婴儿做这件事的那个确切时刻拿起来录一段视频，那这些瞬间似乎就会错失。事实上，你知道，再次想想我们刚开始的时候，如果你想录下一个婴儿的视频。你必须带上一台又大又重的盘式录音机和一箱子的设备，然后祈祷你能捕捉到一些东西。我在想，新的科技是否意味着我们将开始获得更多的数据，并更加赞赏婴儿究竟能做些什么。我们花一分钟来谈谈你的书《园丁与木匠》。你谈到
current parenting culture doesn't really mesh with what science is telling us about the purpose of childhood. Can you explain the difference between a gardener and a carpenter when it comes to parenting and what insights parents and other caregivers should be getting from this work of yours? Yeah. So I think the model, it's interesting that the very word parenting really only started showing up in the 1970s in the United States. Of course, we've had mothers and fathers and parents forever. But the idea that parenting is this occupation, this thing that you do, is relatively recent. And I think the other thing that's relatively recent is a generation of people raising children who hadn't actually really, you know, being the way I was, the oldest of six
当前的育儿文化实际上与科学告诉我们的童年目的并不吻合。你能解释一下育儿方面“园丁”和“木匠”的区别吗，以及父母和其他照顾者应该从你的这项研究中获得什么启示？是的。我认为这种模式——有趣的是，“育儿”（parenting）这个词直到20世纪70年代才在美国开始出现。当然，我们永远都有母亲、父亲和父母。但认为育儿是一种职业、是你所做的一项任务的想法是相对晚近的。我认为另一个相对晚近的现象是，新一代抚养孩子的人实际上并没有——你知道，不像我这样作为六个孩子的老大——此前没有太多抚养孩子的经验，但却有丰富的上学和工作经验。因此，他们倾向于把抚养孩子想像成上学和工作。这是一件拥有一套技术的事情。如果你掌握了正确的技术，并且足够专注，你就能带来正确的结果。
children, hadn't had much experience of raising children before, but had lots of experience of going to school and working. So they tended to think about raising children as being like going to school and working. It's something that you have a bunch of techniques for. If you just get the right technique and you focus enough, you'll be able to bring about the right outcome. It's not quite clear what the right outcome is, but, you know, something like you'll have the child who goes to Harvard, right? And that picture is very, very much not like the picture that comes from thinking about evolution and development. It's almost the opposite of this explorer exploit tradeoff picture that I've been talking about. That picture is a picture where the whole point is to provide children with a rich, safe environment
虽然不太清楚正确的结果是什么，但，你知道的，类似于你会培养出一个去哈佛的孩子，对吧？这种画面与从进化和发展角度思考所得到的画面非常、非常不相似。它几乎与我一直在谈论的“探索-利用权衡”的画面完全相反。那种画面是一个旨在为儿童提供丰富、安全环境的画面，在这个环境中，儿童可以以各种各样不同的方式成长，其中的事物充满变数且无法预测。我曾用来描述这一点的一个比喻是：如果你想想一个木匠，他实际上走出门去，脑子里有一个画面：这就是我要造的椅子，这就是木材，这就是我要做的。如果我非常精确和小心，我就能造出我想要的椅子；而园丁则不同，你根本不知道你的花园里会发生什么。
in which the children can come out in a wide variety of different ways in which things are very variable and unpredictable. A metaphor I've used to try and describe that is if you think about a carpenter who actually goes out and has a picture in their head about here's the chair that I want to build and here's the wood and here's what I'm going to do. And if I'm very precise and careful, I can make exactly the kind of chair that I want versus a gardener where you have no idea what's going to happen in your garden. Or at least from most messy cottage gardeners like me. But also more deeply, one of the things that we've discovered from ecology is that for a garden or any other ecological system to be successful, the key is for it to be variable, for it to be able to do different things in different circumstances, for it to be resilient. So that, you know, when we have a drought the way we have in California, the succulents are going to do really well. and the British cottage garden flowers are not going to do it as well, but it'll reverse when the range come. So having a lot of variability, a lot of difference is one of the things that make systems
或者至少对于像我这样大多数杂乱的小屋园丁来说是这样。但更深层次地讲，生态学告诉我们的一点是，为了让花园或任何其他生态系统取得成功，关键在于保持可变性，在于能够在不同的环境下做不同的事情，在于具备复原力。所以，当我们在加利福尼亚遭遇像现在这样的干旱时，多肉植物会生长得很好，而英国乡村花园的花卉则不会长得那么好，但当雨季来临时，情况就会反过来。因此，拥有大量的变异性和多样性，正是让系统得以繁衍的因素之一
resilient. And the point about childhood is to bring about that kind of unexpected variability in the light of change. So it's just the opposite of what the kind of carpenter parenting picture would suggest. Well, I want to talk for a minute about some of the newer technologies and their role in parenting, and it's not at all uncommon to see parents in malls or restaurants handing toddlers or even babies, mobile phones or iPads to distract them or keep them busy. Is that kind of parenting gardening or carpentering? Can you tell? Well, I think it's important to say that one of the functions of this kind of garden has always been that each generation is dealing with a different universe, a different environment. It's different from the one before. That's one of the things,
具有弹。童年的意义就在于，面对变化，带来那种意料之外的变化性。所以这与木匠式育儿画面所暗示的恰恰相反。好吧，我想花点时间谈谈一些新技术及其在育儿中的角色，在商场或餐厅里看到父母把手机或iPad递给幼儿甚至是婴儿来转移他们的注意力或让他们安静下来，这并不罕见。这种育儿方式是园丁式的还是木匠式的？你能分辨出来吗？嗯，我认为重要的是要指出，这种花园的功能之一一直是，每一代人都在处理一个不同的宇宙，一个不同的环境。它与上一代人不同。这就是其中的一点，
go back to the grandparents, right? That's one of the things about our ability to have culture is that not only do we pass on culture from before, but we also innovate. So we also get new cultural discovery. And part of what childhood has always been about, adolescents particularly, I think, but childhood as well is, all right, I'm in a slightly different environment than I was, than my parents are. How do I cope with that environment? And of course, that's very vivid if you're thinking about, if you're thinking about technology now. So I think, again, COVID has made it really striking. I think all of us have had this experience of the children around us being much better at dealing with Zoom than we are. It's almost a cliche about how quickly
回到祖父母那里，对吧？我们拥有文化的能力的其中一点在于，我们不仅从过去传承文化，而且我们还进行创新。因此，我们也获得了新的文化发现。童年一直以来的部分意义，特别是青少年时期，我认为，但也包括童年，就是，好吧，我身处一个与我以前、与我父母不同的环境中。我如何应对这个环境？当然，如果你正在考虑，如果你现在考虑技术，这就会非常生动。所以我认为，新冠疫情再次使这一点变得非常引人注目。我认为我们所有人都经历过这样的事情，我们周围的孩子比我们更能应付Zoom。关于孩子如何迅速适应这个新世界，这几乎成了一个陈词滥调
children are adapting to this new world compared to adults. But of course, what culture is all about, and that's where the grandmothers come in, is that we always have this, and this again is this point about tradeoffs. We have the way we can do that is because we are passing on the values that we think are important to us, the values that we've discovered, the things that we've found out about the world, we can pass those on to children. And then they're equipped with those values to deal with the new world, which is different from the world that we grew up in. And I think technology is a good example of that. So, you know, I can feel myself, look, standing in front of a screen all day is not a great,
与成年人相比。但当然，文化到底是怎么回事，也就是祖母们发挥作用的地方，就是我们总是拥有这一点，而这再次是关于权衡的点。我们能够做到这一点的方式是因为我们正在传递我们认为对我们很重要的价值观，我们发现的价值观，我们对世界的了解，我们可以把这些传递给孩子们。然后他们就具备了这些价值观来应对新世界，这与我们长大的世界不同。我认为技术就是一个很好的例子。所以，你知道，我可以感觉到自己，看，整天站在屏幕前并不是一个伟大，
happy way to be. And, you know, having the experience of going off into a corner and reading a book or going out into the garden and playing, those are all really good experiences. And I think I can pass that on to my grandchildren at the same time that my grandchildren can figure out, well, how do you, the puzzle that we all have, How do you integrate that with the reality of the new technology? But no matter what, I think they'll never learn penmanship again, right? I mean, you can't impart that particular knowledge.
快乐的生活方式。而且，你知道，有去角落看书或去花园玩的体验，这些都是非常好的体验。我想我可以把这些传给我的孙辈，同时我的孙辈也可以弄清楚，嗯，你如何，我们都有的困惑，你如何将其与新技术现实相结合？但无论如何，我想他们再也不会学书法了，对吧？我的意思是，你无法传授那种特定的知识。
Well, I have to say as a child who was, if I do say so myself, was always extremely good at school, did very well in everything growing up except day of penmanship. I am as a slightly, slightly disgruffing person who can't draw and can't write, I'm willing to give that up. So we've touched a little bit on artificial intelligence. I know that's an area where you become pretty deeply involved in the research. And just wondering, what can AI researchers learn from developmental psychologists and how would AI based on children's learning be different from the way that many AI systems
嗯，我不得不说，作为一个如果我自己这么说的话，小时候在学校总是极其优秀，除了书法课之外，成长过程中什么都做得很好的人。作为一个有点脾气暴躁、不会画画也不会写字的人，我愿意放弃这一点。所以我们稍微谈了一下人工智能。我知道这是一个你深入参与研究的领域。我只是在想，人工智能研究人员可以从发展心理学家那里学到什么，基于儿童学习的人工智能会有什么不同？许多人工智能系统现在正在建设中吗？
are being built right now? Yeah. So, you know, we were talking before about the effect of having women. in the profession and how it changes the kinds of things that we think about. And I think we've had a really nice dramatic example of that recently with AI, where AI's been very heavily dominated by men and the kind of models of AI learning have been obviously dominated by the people who are doing it. But people in AI, you know, for good diversity reasons as well as for intellectual reasons, have started to pay more and more attention to children. And, and
是的。所以，你知道，我们之前谈到了女性在行业中的影响以及它如何改变我们的思考方式。我认为最近人工智能给我们带来了一个非常好的戏剧性例子，人工智能一直被男性大量主导，人工智能学习的模型显然是由做这件事的人主导的。但是人工智能领域的人，你知道，出于良好的多样性原因以及智力原因，已经开始越来越多地关注儿童。而且，并且
And of course, a lot of the people who study children are women. So they've been listening to what women have to say about how children learn. And again, a wonderful thing about AI is these are engineers. And engineers are great about just being willing to take everything, anything into account that will make their machines work better, no matter what other characteristics are. And if you think about AI, I think there's been real interest in children in particular, in quite recently in the past few years because the big advances in AI have been advances in machine learning in learning. So the big discoveries have been that we do better if we actually try to have machines that can learn from the world rather than trying to program in what they should know in the first place.
当然，很多研究孩子的人都是女性。所以他们一直在听取女性对孩子如何学习的看法。同样，人工智能的一个奇妙之处在于这些是工程师。工程师非常乐意将任何能让他们的机器更好地工作的因素考虑进去，无论其他特征如何。如果你考虑人工智能，我认为最近几年人们对儿童产生了真正的兴趣，因为人工智能的重大进展是机器学习和学习方面的进展。所以最大的发现是，如果我们真正尝试让机器从世界中学习，而不是试图在一开始就编程它们应该知道什么，我们会做得更好。
But the kinds of learning that these machines do are pretty limited. So they're, you know, something like here's a giant data set of images and I'm going to tell you label these are cats and these are dogs. And now your job is to say which ones are cats and which ones are dogs. And it's amazing that or you know, here's a game of go and now your job is play a million games ago and then figure out which times what you have to do to win versus lose. And it's amazing that the systems can do as much as they can that way. But the result is that they tend to be quite narrow. So they're good at doing the things that you've trained them to do, but they're not very good at generalizing to new examples.
但是这些机器进行的学习非常有限。所以它们，你知道，就像这里有一个巨大的图像数据集，我要告诉你这些是猫，这些是狗。现在你的工作是说哪些是猫，哪些是狗。令人惊奇的是，或者你知道，这里有一局围棋，现在你的工作是玩一百万局围棋，然后找出你必须做些什么才能赢得比赛与输掉比赛。令人惊奇的是，这些系统能够通过这种方式做这么多事情。但结果是它们往往非常狭隘。所以它们擅长做你训练它们做的事情，但它们不太善于推广到新的例子。
So you give them a slightly unusual picture of a dog, let's say a video of a dog instead of a picture, and they completely bomb out. You change the rules of the game a little bit, and they can't use the things that they learned before. And that makes them very different from children who can have just one or two examples of something that's new and make a really wonderful, unexpected generalization. An example I give a lot again from my grandson is when he was about
所以你给它们一张稍微不寻常的狗的照片，比如说狗的视频而不是照片，它们就完全搞砸了。你稍微改变一下游戏规则，它们就无法使用之前学到的东西。这使得它们与能够仅凭一两个新事物的例子就做出非常精彩、意想不到的泛化的儿童截然不同。我经常再次从我孙子身上举的一个例子是，当他大约
for his grandfather said, gee, I wish I could be a kid again. And Augie said, why didn't you try don't eat any broccoli and don't eat any green beans and don't eat any healthy food? And then maybe you could be a kid again. Now, that's a wonderful, you know, that's my brilliant grandson, but any four-year-olds will give you examples like this, where it's not like anyone had told him that, but of course you can see the rationale behind it, right? If eating vegetables turns you from a kid into a big, strong grown-up,
四岁时，他的祖父说，天哪，我希望我能再当一次小孩。奥吉说：“你为什么不试试不吃任何西红钱、不吃任何青豆、不吃任何健康食品？然后也许你就能再当一次小孩了。”现在，这是一个极好的，你知道，这是我聪明的孙子，但任何四岁的孩子都会给你这样的例子，这并不是说有人告诉过他，但你当然可以看到背后的逻辑，对吧？如果吃蔬菜能让你从一个小孩变成一个又大又壮的成年人，
then you should be able to reverse the process. And that's an example of something where without any explicit supervision, without anybody telling you what the answer is, you think of something that's a really good generalization, a really good creative new idea. And that's one of the things that three and four-year-olds are fantastic at doing. That's part of why it's so much fun to just listen to them talk. So that's one thing that the children can do.
那么你应该能够逆转这个过程。这是一个例子，在没有任何明确监督的情况下，在没有人告诉你答案的情况下，你想到了一个非常好的泛化、一个非常好的创造性新想法。这是三四岁的小孩子非常擅长的事情之一。这也是为什么听他们说话这么有趣的部分原因。所以这是孩子们能做的一件事。
So how is it that they do it? And we think that there's, so I've been part of a big project that DARPA, the defense research group that actually helped invent the internet and modern computers, DARPA is funding to try and see if we could design an artificial system that was as smart as an 18-month-old, say. And the things that we think are really crucial that makes the children different from current chaos is that they build models of the world.
那么他们究竟是如何做到这一点的呢？我们认为，所以我是美国国防高级研究计划局（DARPA）一个大型项目的一部分，该国防研究机构实际上帮助发明了互联网和现代计算机，DARPA正在资助该项目，试图看看我们是否能设计一个像18个月大的孩子一样聪明的系统。我们认为对使儿童与当前混乱状态有所不同至关重要的东西是，他们构建了对世界的模型。
They're not just looking at statistics. They're actually thinking of things like, okay, how does eating turn you into a grown-up? Importantly, they explore. So instead of being sort of stuck in their main frames, you know, we children are out there doing experiments all the time. When they do it, we call it getting into everything. But they're getting into everything. They're going out and actually getting information. And there's a lot of exciting work now in
他们不仅仅是在看统计数据。他们实际上在思考诸如，好吧，吃东西是如何让你变成成年人的？重要的是，他们会探索。因此，孩子们并没有被困在他们的主机里，而是在一直做实验。当他们这样做时，我们称之为介入一切。但他们正在介入一切。他们出去并实际获取信息。现在有很多令人兴奋的工作
AI trying to make curious AI, that's part of what we've been doing at Berkeley. Could we make AIs that are curious the way that children are? And it looks as if that makes them much smarter than when they're not curious. And then a third thing is that this cultural piece that we learn from other people. So children are imitating, you know, literally from the time they're born. And they imitate in very smart, sophisticated ways. It isn't just kind of mindless copying. They're thinking a lot about what is it that the other person around me is trying to teach me. The work that I did in the first part of my career back in the 80s was what came to be called theory of mind.
人工智能试图制造好奇的人工智能，这就是我们在伯克利一直在做的一部分。我们能制造出像孩子一样好奇的人工智能吗？看起来这比它们不好奇时要聪明得多。第三点是我们从其他人那里学到的文化部分。所以孩子们从出生起就在模仿，而且他们以非常聪明、复杂的方式模仿。这不仅仅是一种无意识的抄袭。他们正在认真思考我周围的另一个人试图教我什么。我在职业生涯早期（80年代）所做的工作后来被称为心理理论。
How do we understand what's going on in the minds of other people? Again, when we started in the 80s, there wasn't even a word for this. Nobody quite thought of it as being something that would be interesting to find out about. Now it's kind of an industry. And one of the things that, again, people in AI have realized is if you want an AI that works like a person, it needs to understand people. It needs to have a theory of mind. And it needs to use that to try to learn from other people. So can you have a robot that could see someone do something?
我们如何理解其他人心中发生的事情？同样，当我们在80年代开始时，甚至没有一个词来形容这一点。没有人认为这是一个有趣的事情。现在它有点像一个行业。同样，人工智能领域的人意识到的事情之一是，如果你想要一个像人一样工作的人工智能，它就需要了解人。它需要有一个心理理论。它需要利用这一点来试图向其他人学习。那么你能不能有一个机器人可以看到某人做某事？
And it's sort of fascinating. It's been a wonderful learning experience for me. You know, if you talk to people in robotics, for instance, and you think, okay, well, this should be easy, right? You'll just show the robot that someone's reaching for something and it'll imitate. But it turns out what the robot will do is imitate exactly the absolute trajectory of what the person does. And then if you just move the object over an inch, it'll fail because it doesn't know what it's supposed to what it's supposed to do. Whereas the kids will figure out what is it that you want me to do? Is that the right kind of thing to do? What would be a better way of doing it? They're they're doing this in a much more sophisticated way.
这有点迷人。对我来说这是一次极好的学习经历。你知道，如果你与机器人专家交谈，并且你认为，好吧，这应该很容易，对吧？你只需向机器人展示某人正在伸手去拿东西，它就会模仿。但事实证明，机器人会做的是完全模仿人所做的绝对轨迹。然后如果你把物体移动一英寸，它就会失败，因为它不知道它应该做什么。而孩子们会弄清楚你到底想让我做什么？那是正确的事情吗？有什么更好的方法吗？他们正在以一种更加复杂的方式做到这一点。
So that's another big piece, especially in robotics that that people are trying to do based on based on what the kids are doing. So we both are finding out more about how kids brains and minds work by trying to say what program are they using that would enable them to learn so much. That's been the big question that I've been asking all along. But that also means that we might be able to actually design some systems that are better at learning.
所以这是另一个重要的部分，特别是在机器人领域，人们正试图根据孩子们正在做的事情来做。因此，我们都在通过试图说明他们正在使用什么程序来使他们能够学到这么多东西，来更多地了解儿童的大脑和思维是如何工作的。这是我一直以来一直在问的重大问题。但这同时也意味着我们也许能够真正设计出一些更擅长学习的系统。
And then the last thing, which is the most recent thing that I've been working on that I've been most involved in over this last year, year is part of the reason also why children can learn so much is because they have these caring adults around them who are taking care of them and also giving them the kind of information they need to be able to learn. And I'm getting more and more interested again, maybe this is partly being a grandmother, what is involved in being that kind of a caring adult? And it turns out that that's actually very important, oddly enough, in AI, because one of the big problems in AI, it's called the
最后一件事情，也是我最近一直在做的事情，是我在过去的一年里参与最多的事情，孩子们之所以能学到这么多东西，部分原因也是因为他们身边有这些充满关爱的成年人在照顾他们，同时也为他们提供学习所需的信息。我对这个话题越来越感兴趣，也许这部分是因为当了祖母，成为那种关爱他人的成年人需要什么？事实说明，这其实非常重要，奇怪的是，在人工智能中，因为人工智能中有一个大问题，叫做
alignment problem is how could we get AIs that had the same values that we do? So, you know, the big fear about the AIs are going to kill us, which is probably not going to happen. But there's still a question about how do you tell an AI this is what you're trying to do. And it turns out, you know, with humans, it's very hard to actually articulate what is important. What's the value that what's the value that we're trying for? You know, the famous example is like you tell an AI to make paper clips. Does it turn everything in the world into a paper. It's people in AI call it the paperclip apocalypse, right?
对齐问题是我们如何才能让人工智能拥有与我们相同的价值观？所以，你知道，关于人工智能会杀死我们的巨大恐惧，这可能不会发生。但仍然有一个问题，那就是你如何告诉人工智能这是你正在努力做的事情。事实证明，你知道，对于人类来说，很难真正表达什么才是最重要的。我们追求的价值是什么？你知道，著名的例子就像你告诉人工智能制作回形针。它会把世界上的一切都变成回形针吗？人工智能领域的人称之为回形针末日，对吧？
Does everything turn into a paperclip? Because you haven't told it, no, no, no, just these things turn into paper clips. And actually, if you think about parenting or being a parent, we face that problem all the time, right? So we want our children to be able to develop new values, develop new goals that aren't the same as ours, but that are good, that are important,
一切都会变成回形针吗？因为你没有告诉它，不，不，不，只有这些东西才会变成回形针。实际上，如果你考虑育儿或成为父母，我们一直都在面临这个问题，对吧？所以我们希望我们的孩子们能够发展出新的价值观，发展出与我们不尽相同但却是好的、重要的目标，
that are not beneficent, right? beneficent rather than negative. So this kind of cultural trade-off of tradition, grandma telling you the values that she had 100 years ago, and then you having to take them and adapt them to a world of Zoom screens, that's actually a problem that we have with AI as well. If we're going to actually have genuinely intelligent AI,
不是行善的，对吧？是行善而不是消极的。因此，传统文化的这种权衡，奶奶告诉你她100年前拥有的价值观，然后你不得不接受它们并将它们适应Zoom屏幕的世界，这实际上也是我们在人工智能方面遇到的问题。如果我们真的要拥有真正智能的人工智能，
we're going to have to figure out some way that we can pass on, here's what our values and goals are, here's what's important, here's what's good. And also enable the AI to be able to generalize, to discover and think of goals in a new way. And I think that's one of the main problems in AI ethics is how can we, if we want systems that are, we want them to be autonomous,
我们必须想出某种方法，将我们的价值观和目标传递下去，什么是重要的，什么是好的。同时也使人工智能能够泛化，以一种新的方式发现和思考目标。我认为这是人工智能伦理学的主要问题之一，我们如何才能做到这一点，如果我们希望系统是，我们希望它们是自主的，
we don't want to be sitting there and telling them every single thing that they can do, but we want them to be good and we want them to do the things that we think are important. And actually, that's exactly the problem that every generation of caregivers face. And the more I've thought about it, again, I think COVID has made it very vivid that caregiving is something that is absolutely crucial and central to human cognition and progress and human life.
我们不想坐在那里告诉它们它们可以做的每一件小事，但我们希望它们是善良的，我们希望它们做我们认为重要的事情。实际上，这正是每一代看护者面临的问题。我越是思考这个问题，再次认为，新冠疫情使人们非常生动地认识到，护理是绝对至关重要且核心于人类认知、进步和人类生活的事情。
And yet again, as with children in general, it's very neglected. No one's thought about it very much. The moral philosophers don't think about it. It doesn't fit the kind of models that we typically have in our politics. And yet, you know, that individual elder. care worker who cares about that person who's sick and is willing to, you know, risk their own health and take care of them, even though they're paid nothing and they're treated incredibly, incredibly badly. I think there's something so deep about humankind there that we we haven't
然而，与一般儿童一样，它再次被非常忽视。没有多少人认真思考过它。道德哲学家不考虑它。它不符合我们政治中通常拥有的那种模式。然而，你知道，那个照顾那个生病的人并愿意冒着自己健康的风险去照顾他们的个人老年护理工作者，尽管他们没有得到任何报酬，而且受到了难以置信的糟糕对待。我认为人类身上有某种如此深厚的东西，我们还没有
thought about very much. We haven't understood in psychological or cognitive or cognitive terms. Or again, you know, watching this grandchild, this new grandchild and, you know, within three weeks. He was actually early. He was premature. And yet, here's this tiny little creature and here's these grownups who just care more about him than anything else
思考得太多。我们还没有在心理、认知或认知术语中理解它。或者再次，你知道，看着这个孙子，这个新孙子，在三周内。他其实很早就出生了。他是个早产儿。然而，这里有这么一个小小的生物，这里有这些成年人，他们只是比世界上任何事情都更关心他
in the world. That's an amazing human capacity that we haven't thought about very much and we don't understand very well. So that's kind of the thing that's kind of on the cutting edge of what I've been doing with my time over the last year. Well, maybe, and this is kind of a last question,
这是一个惊人的中国人类能力，我们还没有过多思考，也没有很好地理解。所以这就是我过去一年时间里一直在做的事情的前沿。好吧，也许，这也是最后一个问题，
but I think that you perhaps have answered in many ways in just this last topic that we were discussing. But do you think that there's still anything that could surprise you about children's minds after all these years of studying them? Yeah, well, of course, in detail, this is really true. Every time we do an experiment in the lab, we get surprised. So it's a, you know, I'm used to the fact that we'll do a pilot and I'll say, yeah, I'm positive the four-year-olds are going to be able to do this.
但我认为你可能在我们刚刚讨论的最后一个话题中以多种方式回答了这个问题。但是你认为在研究了这么多年的儿童思维之后，是否还有什么事情能让你对儿童的思维感到惊讶？是的，当然，具体来说，这确实如此。每次我们在实验室做实验，我们都会感到惊讶。所以这是一个，你知道，我已经习惯了这样一个事实，即我们将做一个试点，我会说，是的，我确信四岁的孩子能够做到这一点。
I've got, you know, 40 years of experience, I know, and they do something completely. They do something completely unlike, completely unlike what I would have thought. Or vice versa. My student says, how about we try this? We had an experiment recently trying to see if children could understand this, some very abstract ideas from AI about variable choice where I'd say, no, that, come on, that's something that they couldn't possibly understand. And they're, you know, like the two-year-olds are doing it in minutes. So I think there's no question that they're going to continue to do things that are really surprising that I wouldn't have anticipated, but I wouldn't have anticipated in the first place, which of course is part of why it's so much more fun to study them than it is to study any other creatures. Well, this has been really interesting and a lot of fun, Dr. Gopnik. Really, thank you for joining me today.
我有，你知道，40年的经验，我知道，他们做了一些完全不同的事情。他们做的事情完全不同，完全不同于我想象的。或者反过来。我的学生说，我们试试这个怎么样？我们最近做了一个实验，试图看看孩子们是否能理解这一点，一些来自人工智能关于变量选择的非常抽象的想法，我会说，不，拜托，那是他们绝对不可能理解的东西。他们，你知道，就像两岁的孩子在几分钟内就做到了。所以我认为毫无疑问，他们将继续做一些真正令人惊讶的事情，这是我事先没有预料到的，而我一开始就没有预料到，当然这也是为什么研究他们比研究任何其他生物更有趣的部分原因。好吧，这真的很有趣，而且非常开心，高普尼克博士。真的，谢谢你今天加入我。
Well, it's always great to talk to you and to talk to all the APA listeners. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondy. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，与你以及所有的APA听众交谈总是很棒。谢谢你。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学之声》的往期节目。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。心理学之声由莉·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。